Jason stark back here on the show how
you been Jason rich I'm good but I'm not
wearing a blazer do you not so what I
mean not do I want to ask you what
you're wearing right now Jason my
standard writing attire
be sure to ensure that a boy well done
you we were talking last hour and
talking all week just the way things are
shaping up in the American League it's
entirely possible that we have to 100
win teams battle it out for a wild card
one and done battle in the playoffs
Jason right yeah
very possible you know we've never had a
hundred win team playing the wild-card
game and I think we're definitely gonna
get that I don't know if we're gonna get
two but I think we're definitely gonna
get that this time around we'll get one
right and you know I if nothing else I
think this turns this Yankees Red Sox
race and then the best race between
those two teams probably since 1978
Bucky Dent you know there there are some
races in the 90s and the early 2000s
where they were the two best teams but
back then there was no such thing as a
wild card game and there's no real
penalty for the wild card and they
didn't even care if they finished first
that's not going to be true this year
because if you're the wild card just
think of the path it's a treacherous
path you got to survive that wild card
game you know they are the red flags
you've got to spend Chris Sale to do it
he made the beat James Paxton to do it
now you're going to go faced the best
team in that league another 100 win team
it'll be Astros or could be Mariners
could be Yankees it this is no way to
try to get to the World Series so
winning the AL East has never been more
important than it will be this year well
I mean you mentioned the 78 Yankees Red
Sox I mean that was a year the Boston
Massacre when the Yankees came from 14
back only to be four back going to
Fenway and then sweeping it all and then
that led to that one game playoff with
Bucky Dent et cetera et cetera I mean I
don't see either one of these
teams being more than a game were two in
front of the other all year long
that said I imagine the July deadline
will will be important for both of these
teams also how do you see that shaping
up Jason yeah absolutely I mean this
often comes down to the team that makes
the best deal and you know the the
Yankees have been incredible they have
not lost a series in the second week of
April but as they look at their team I
think they feel like they need a game
two starter maybe a game two in game
three starter in the postseason and so
they'll be really aggressive looking for
starting pitching in July the Red Sox I
think a lot depends on health but their
their lineups been great their rotation
is built for October given else I mean I
would think right now that bullpen would
be the area they would want to attack
that that group leading up to Craig
Kimbrel at the end but stay tuned you
know health really affect a lot of this
stuff and you know right now we're in a
really early stages of the pre deadline
chatter Jason stark here on the Rich
Eisen show how do you see it playing out
with with Manny Machado though that's
definitely gonna happen
correct well it should
the oils know right now they're in the
middle of a lost season and there's
probably no more interesting name
leading up to the deadline and Manny
we're gonna spend the next five six
weeks talking about him non-stop I know
that but you know the Orioles move
really slowly very deliberately and you
know some question in the minds of teams
that have talked to them who really has
the final call on what happens with
Manny and so that could cause some
issues as they head for the deadline and
another thing to watch is you know Manny
wanted to play shortstop this year but
you know things that have talked to the
Orioles are saying that they're willing
to trade them to somebody that will play
him at third base you might not be happy
about that but it obviously
widens their field as they try to stoke
some kind of bidding war and there could
be a lot of plot lines running through
the Manny Machado stuff so stay tuned
Jason stark here on the Rich Eisen show
the Dodgers coming back from the dead
has been remarkable how did how they
done it Jason well you know we haven't
had a team that was 10 games under 500
that survived to make the postseason
since of 2009 Rockies and only been two
teams in history there were ever 10
games under and won the World Series
there's a 2003 Marlins and the miracle
Braves so if miracles in your nickname
you know how it is right but they've had
some amazing things happen like Ross
stripling and Max Monte and Matt Kemp
saving the Dodgers season is not a
sentence I thought I would ever utter
but that's really what happened right
and now they're starting to get healthy
after surviving this incredible period
where they had basically an all-star
rotation on the disabled list the
Diamondbacks have had such a bizarre
year 20 and 8 in April never lost a
series then eight and 19 in May now
twelve and six in June so I don't know
exactly what they are but this does have
a chance to be a fun race and then
there's the all-star game obviously
coming up next month do you think Bryce
Harper's future will be front and center
what's going to be the main storyline we
go to Washington DC for for the all-star
game you know rich Bryce has been trying
to shut down that talk stress ever since
they want a spring training I don't know
how easy it'll be for him to do that in
that setting he and Manny Machado are
going to be the marquee free agents just
because of name and star power and
they're there that that's going to come
up any neither one of them can really
stop it I'm sure they won't be
comfortable with it but we get to the
last hour game it's people like us who
get to determine you know what the
storyline
until they actually start playing so
I'll be interested to see how they
answered those questions price has had
such an odd year I'm not worried about
him getting paid like he's 25 years old
but we're gonna get paid four hundred
five hundred six hundred million based
on the way he's swinging the bat right
now good luck on that yeah I know he's
in a deep slump in a slump in funk but
when it all comes down to it I mean he
Washington can't just let him walk for
nothing so where do you think it's gonna
what do you think's gonna happen with
him well they're not gonna trade them
they're gonna try to win the World
Series with there they're built to win
and I'm you just saw them go out and
trade for Kelvin Herrera in the name of
winning it is the most important year in
history of their franchise since they
got to DC and they're gonna ride it out
with Bryce they'll offer him the
qualifying offer I don't know that
anybody expects it when there's dust
settles and the you know they if
somebody signs on the dotted line that
he'll wind up back in Washington but
their plan has always been to try to win
with them
Jason stark here on the Rich Eisen show
a couple more minutes left with the with
Jason
so when it all comes down to it you're
talking with chato
on the market what big name pitchers
might be out there do you think you know
there's been something that I would say
worries the Yankees quite a bit you know
we talked about them wanting a trade for
a game two story starter you know that
guy might not be out there and that's a
problem you know Cole Hamels Jay Happ
they can help your team but they're not
what we're used to
now if the mess decide they really are
serious about wanting to trade Jacob
degrom or Noah syndergaard which I'm
dubious about get back to me if the Rays
were to decide they would be willing to
trade Chris Archer get back to me but
it's possible there won't be a single
top of the rotation starter who gets
traded in July mm-hmm well that would
be a problem for a team that's looking
for an ASA in July to try and go pitch
for pitch with somebody like Houston or
the Red Sox when it all comes down to it
now what where does the hunter strikland
story rank for you Jason in terms of
strange odd self when you wanted north
the doors are always undefeated and I
thought somebody was joking on Twitter
that the door edge homered off 103 years
ago so he finally executive and well
yeah punching stuff after you blow a
save right almost always when you punch
the door or the wall or the don't break
the lightbulbs or whatever they had
nothing to do with it so it's just not I
just don't recommend it right
and this has been kind of the story of
the Giants here you know and just want
to think things are starting to move in
the direct right direction something
goofy like this happens and one last one
we haven't really hitter on this show I
know Brockman and a bunch of MLB fans
certainly enjoyed seeing the the r-rated
microphone converse miked up picked up
conversation if you will between Terry
Collins and the name of the umpire
escapes me right now I'm sure you know
off the top of your head Jason that well
know what that actually got taken down
before after watch it well I saw it I
saw it and it's it's behind its you want
to call it inside baseball it was really
fascinating to see but I understand why
baseball took it down because you know
that's the sort of stuff that umpires
sure that where Mike's for you for for
entertainment purposes but that sort of
stuff where their work in blue and
talking about their thoughts on Major
League Baseball shouldn't be put out
there do we know how that got out there
Jason or his baseball still looking in
that that's you know yeah they're
investigating the UMP was Tom Hallion by
the way and Rob Manfred talked about
this last week at the owners meetings
they don't understand how this got out
there's a limited number of people who
theoretically would have access to that
sort of video and you know it's going to
be interesting to see a if
ever figure it out and be if they ever
tell us he had some ulterior motives man
I bet I bet thanks for the call Jason
appreciate it we'll chat down a line
rich always a pleasure buddy you gotta
that's MLB network's Jason Stark the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience